[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon face à ces grands ici c'est trop
beau c'est vrai c'est bout devant une
salle pleine à craquer et qui plus est
une salle remplie d'anonymes
bah oui c'est compliqué de savoir qui se
cache derrière ces masques bon pour moi
c'est plutôt rassurant de me dire que là
c'est peut-être pas andy macdowell nancy
une dame qui a des cheveux des grands
yeux et des oreilles
enfin quand même on a déjà dû vous le
dire vous avez le même regard qu'elle
sait peut-être assurant pour vous aussi
d'ailleurs parce que on dit tout le
temps que cannes c'est fait pour voir et
être vu mais c'est agréable si le
pouvoir voir sans se montrer
alors cette année c'est vraiment un
retour au cinéma au sens premier du
terme quoi on est au cinéma pour voir
comme n'importe quel spectateur du monde
juste un spectateur qui vient voir un
fils qui est content de voir un filles
vierges de tout a priori
moi je pense que pour être un bon
spectateurs ont pas résisté faut
s'abandonner
alors pendant 11 jours on va pas
résister on va voir des filles on va
être surpris on va pleurer
on va rire on va s'ennuyer peut-être
parfois mais c'est bien aussi parce que
ça laisse le temps de penser on va
partager et qui sait peut-être repartir
différent parce que c'est quand même le
but d'un film enfin bien sûr ça marche
pas à tous les coups si chacune ne
changeait les membres du jury
repartirait totalement schizophrène
c'est pas c'est pas facile de faire
évoluer les mentalités
on peut pas imposer une vision des
cinémas lui permet de la proposer parce
qu'un film c'est pas autoritaire l'art
parfois ça peut être violent mais ça
reste une des façons les plus douces
d'exprimer une chose violentes ou une
chose non violente une chose une chose
drôle une chose tendre bizarre
impossible c'est peut-être ça qu'on
appelle la magie du cinéma
alors je sais qu'il ya des phrases
toutes faites qui peuvent faire peur
dans une cérémonie d'ouverture
la magie du cinéma mais moi en vrai
j'adore la magie
ce que j'aime dans la magie c'est le
travail qu'il ya derrière et qu'on voit
pas une fois j'avais rencontré un
magicien mais enfin il se présentait pas
comme un magicien il était juste la
normale en jean baskets et il fait un
premier tour sympa mais bon voilà on se
dit oui il avait caché une carte dans sa
manche
sauf qu'il était en tee shirt et hélas
il s'est bien enchaîné les tours il est
disparaître des billets il fait
apparaître des fleurs mais mais comme ce
à quoi a l'air de rien mais ça
s'arrêtait jamais il devinait des dates
de naissance il sortait une colombe
enfin franchement je t'ai bouleversant
et moi je me disais mais c'est pas
possible à un moment donné va arriver au
bout il peut pas avoir peu près autant
de trucs mais si
il avait préparé autant de
[Musique]
parce que la vérité
fait logique en fait c'est qu'il avait
passé sa vie à préparer sa vie à
s'entraîner pour avoir le geste parfait
non c'est pas une phrase toute faite
le cinéma c'est des milliers d'heures de
travail
c'est
une coiffeuse en équilibre sur une
échelle pour replacer une mèche rebelle
c'est des dizaines de figurants maillot
quand il fait 4 degrés au bord de l'eau
c'est un acteur qui trempe de tout son
corps tellement il se rend ridicule et
qui va sourire à la caméra comme s'il
avait pris 3 ecstasy charles
accessoiristes qui fait des trous avec
une aiguille dans une cigarette pour
qu'une petite fille de 9 ans et demi
puisse la fumée
c'est une réalisatrice qui change tout
la mise en place de caméras et qui
oblige cinq ans technicien à rentrer
chez eux à 2 heures du matin parce
qu'elle comprend de cette chaîne doit
être filmé depuis l'autre côté de la
fenêtre c'est des pylônes de stade de
foot pour éclairer un plat de spaghetti
est une actrice qui donne la réplique à
un morceau de scotch vert fluo et c'est
un monteur qui jettent 95% tout ce
travail en se demandant s'il n'est pas
en train de jeter le meilleur c'est tous
ces petits bouts de ficelle qu'on
attache en sang
pour que les 5% qui restent nous
provoque une émotion
c'est ça la magie 10 yens
[Applaudissements]